das ist quasi ein kleiner schritt für
die menschheit aber ein riesiger sprung
für die dänische raumfahrtindustrie
obwohl industrie es sind amateure
raumfahrttechniker anfang august gelang
es ihnen ihre selbst gebaute rakete in
eine höhe von 600 kilometern zu
befördern
ein voller erfolg vor allem wenn man
bedenkt welche materialien sie für den
bau der rakete verwendet haben das
glaubt wirklich niemand und auch ihr
ziel ist verrückt der erste bemannte
amateur raumflug kriegs um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
4000 meter 5000 meter 6000 meter und
mehr dann geht der fallschirm auf und
die selbstgebaute nächste 2 rakete kehrt
kontrolliert zur erde zurück die
dänischen raumfahrt amateure können ihr
glück kaum fassen mehr als sechs
kilometer hoch hat es die rakete des
hobby tüftler vereins copenhagen
software mittels also in die luft
geschafft auch wenn das nur ein kleiner
zwischenschritt zur verwirklichung ihrer
großen vision ist denn zukünftig wollen
sie einen menschen ins all schicken als
erste amateure weltweit schon jetzt sind
sie die ersten überhaupt weltweit die
erfolgreich raketen bauen dazu einer der
verantwortlichen techniker jörgens gut
es lief fantastisch nichts ging schief
eigentlich erwarten wir dass etwas
schief geht wenn wir einen staat haben
aber diesmal klappte alles vollständig
perfekt und der veranstalter ergänzt das
ist bei diesem testflug gar nicht mal so
sehr um die höhe ging vielmehr habe man
wert darauf gelegt dass der antrieb
mindestens 40 sekunden lang durchhalte
die rakete gerade fliegen und die rakete
auch wieder in der ostsee lande und den
theoretischen berechnungen der amateure
hätte die raketen excel 2 sogar bis zu
15 kilometer hoch fliegen können der
start gelang von einer schwimmenden
plattform auf der ostsee nahm sputnik
eine genehmigung für den staat vom land
aus wäre wohl kaum vorstellbar gewesen
der start der 178 kilogramm schweren
rakete war übrigens um eine woche
verlegt worden denn wegen der schlimmen
waldbrände in schweden konnten die
behörden nicht für die sicherheit des
luftraums garantieren nach dem öffnen
des fallschirms fiel die rakete
kontrolliert ins meer zurück und war so
sicher in der nähe der dänischen
ostseeinsel bornholm gelandet die
raumfahrt amateure wie sie sich selbst
nennen benutzen für den bau ihrer rakete
übrigens durchaus kurioses material
nämlich das was man auch für
herkömmliche drucker und kaffeemaschinen
verwendet dazu vereinssprecher matt
wilson wir zeigen dass man mit
herkömmlichen material unglaublich weit
kommen kann
denn der bau von raketen seien nicht nur
etwas für staaten die über millionen
budgets verfügen schon seit jahren
arbeiten sie auf ihr langfrist ziel hin
und zwar mit bis zu 60 freiwilligen
schon seit 2011 basteln sie an raketen
und raumkapseln und haben bereits fünf
stück fertig gestellt und ebenfalls von
einem schiff in der ostsee abgeschossen
excel 1 hatten sie vor zwei jahren also
2016 gestartet doch das weit weniger
erfolgreich sie kamen nur 1500 meter
hoch dann ging ihr der treibstoff aus
die idee geht übrigens auch peter madsen
zurück er wurde ja wegen des mordes an
kim wohl auf seinem auto zu lebenslanger
haft verurteilt 2008 hatte er das
projekt gegründet 2014 kam es zum streit
mit den anderen mitgliedern und er
verließ den verein auch wenn es jetzt
einen großen erfolg gehabt wenn man mal
ehrlich ist wird die vision der
dänischen tüftler wahrscheinlich noch
etwas länger reines wunschdenken bleiben
denn die grenze zwischen erdatmosphäre
und weltraum die liegt in 100 kilometern
höhe
dennoch zeigt die tests flug allemal das
hobby tüftler mit kleinen mitteln
großartiges auf die beine stellen können
und ihr könnt den raketenbau direkt hier
auf youtube folgen einfach hier
draufklicken und den kanal der
copenhagen service abonnieren und wenn
er kein video zum thema astronomie und
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann
umgeht er die etwas unzuverlässige abo
boxee auf youtube und wertet sogar vorab
über neue videos von mir informiert
einfach hier draufklicken und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch dortigen
zeitenwende in allen neue falcon 9
version also bis dann bleibt dran